[Music]
um as s you said my name is Matthew
Henry I come well I grew up in France so
you might notice some accent um sorry
about that but actually I come from Oslo
Norway where I work as a JavaScript
developer for Oprah the web browser
company we're pretty cool I'm I'm not a
developer relations yet they covered for
me to to come here and um
during the day I work as a JavaScript
developer um on the on Opera for
computers so everything we write there
is all nice and clean it's es6
everything goes through code review
nothing goes to Main Line without being
checked by one or two developers getting
approval and we ship code every week to
about 60 million users monthly so it's
um it's nice and uh thanks to Oprah and
J K I'm here today with my family this
is my daughter she's crazy about animals
and uh we heard that the the the
aquarium of Singapore is pretty awesome
so that's her plan for a day and I hope
one day she will come and speak to a
conference like this to talk about her
work and her passion and that's what I'm
here to talk
about I'm here to talk to you about tiny
audio visual demos and how to make them
so to go through a talk today um I will
explain what I mean by tiny audio visual
demos and where I come from
then some general tips about how to make
them some wild tricks and then it will
be coding
time so tiny audio visual
demos
um what do I mean by that and where I
come from the javascrip community knows
me more as P1 uh for the small
animations and Creations that I make um
I am into code golfing and creative
coding the things you you see in the
background hope it's not too dark uh
small Productions that I made they all
range from 64 bytes yes bytes to 1
kilobyte and we all do some kind of
animations or interactive things with
sound or not um code golfing is the art
of reducing the code size to some
ridiculous like to the smallest possible
and creative coding is the art or is the
practice of using code to create art I'm
not the only one doing these kind of
things uh you probably remember Martin
Clipper who was here last year to talk
about these kind of things is also into
obstrusive code and artistic code so he
likes to make code that looks pretty on
the outside and makes nice things um but
this is not where I come from I come
from the demo scene maybe you heard
about
this uh this is a subculture that was
born about 31 years ago in Berlin um and
basically the essense of a demos scene
is it's about packing the most bang for
your bck with style it's about making
really cool animations and really push
the envelope of the platform no matter
no matter the platform So This is Where
I Come From I'm into making cool things
as small as possible and trying to push
things in Corners that you did not
expect this is what I mean and where I
come from about tiny
demos um now for some general
tips you have to focus when you want to
make a a small demo you have to focus
really focus on the core of what it is
you're trying to achieve don't don't try
to yeah don't try to diverge just do
what you what you want to do what you
need to do nothing
more so when you work around 1 kilobyte
and even up to 4 4 kiloby um well the
size itself does not matter but the J
Community is crazy about Frameworks we
heard the number of 150 180,000 modules
on
mpm this is not the place for that here
you you just go and create and there's
no need for libraries or Frameworks just
roll your own things it's okay um as
much as possible you should try to use
one primitive it can be particles can be
lines can be triangles polygons anything
squares you name it but using a single
primitive will basically put one more
constraint on you and it will just drive
your ctivity it will push you into
Corners you did not
expect and in the same Ida you should
try to use a single formula one single
formula to drive the whole animation to
drive the sound and to drive the visuals
that way it makes things more coupled
together and More in
sync so really it is about Focus you
need to focus and plan what you're
doing this is how you make tiny a a
visual
demos now for some wild tricks when you
make animations you often need to play
with a bit of trigonometry just to make
things move around up and down or in
circles um so you need to use Senus
cinus pi and fractions of Pi um and
things don't need to be 100% accurate
it's it's okay to use approximations the
numbers you see above are just
approximations of fractions of Pi and
it's okay to use them it things don't
need to be 100% perfect you you're not
shipping to customers no one is going to
die if things are slightly off by two
pixels or three pixels no
problem um as you probably know numbers
in JavaScript and in many of programming
languages um are using the I e754
standard it basically defines how
numbers are represented they presented
in binary as a composition of powers of
twos and fractions of powers of twos um
and this leads to so-called floating
Point errors in JavaScript and many
other languages if you do 0.2 plus 0.1
you don't get 0.3 as you would expect
you get
0.34 which is right and wrong at the
same time which is right according to a
standard this is wrong from what you
would expect um and this lead to things
like this you see this Loop that goes
from 0 to 10 with a increment of Z .1 it
exits fine and no problem but at the end
look I is not equal to 10 I is equal to
10.0
99999 which is correct according to the
standard but not what you would
expect but if you use the the standard
to your advantage and use an increment
that is a fraction of power two then all
the numbers that you that are expressed
during this Loop are exact they are they
are exactly what you expect and and they
are correct according to the standard
and that gives you some nice properties
like you can use modul on that and you
can also do strict equality on values
yeah in this Loop you could do in strict
equality to one or five or 10 or
5.5 and it works it works nicely you
yeah so use the standard or know the
standard and try to use them to your
advantage it gives some really nice
properties there will be no audio visual
demos without music and to do sound on
the web there's two two ways there's be
web JPI which we saw yesterday with Paul
um it's extremely powerful you can
generate sounds oscillators load sounds
decode apply filters and these kind of
things and this be audio element which
is much more limited you can just load
the sound and play it um but as I said I
come from the demo scene and in the
regular 1 kiloby and 4 kiloby demos
people pregenerate big sound buffer at
the beginning of the demo and then they
just replay it and run the visuals in
real time on top of that and that fits
perfectly with the with the audio
element uh the code you see here is a
bit yeah it's about 200 bytes of code in
itself it's not important the first two
lines just set the header of a wave file
the second two mdle lines add to the
sound buffer and the last two lines play
the sound buffer that's all you need to
get sound and to create music um
it's a bit like what you we saw
yesterday with Paul um the first line
here just creates noise second second
line add an exponential decay and the
last line adds that to the sound buffer
so what we get is like a white nose with
an exponential decay and that's
basically a high
just goes like this so using small bits
of code like this you can build
music you will need colors of course and
you will be tempted to use HS to make
color shift you across time it's really
nice but hsl passing is incredibly slow
um do 1,000 of these into your into your
frame and it will take just 10
millisecond just to pass the hsl colors
this is unbelievably so um you have 16
milliseconds to render one frame to get
60 frames per second animation and you
get just 10 milliseconds on that so try
to avoid hsl and in instead use
something like this it looks a bit crazy
but basically what it does it just
varies the r g and B component along the
S and it just detunes them by the third
of a circle so it does this U shift
exactly the same and it's an order of
magnitude
faster Shadow BL um I've been using 2D
canas for about 10 years and for all
this time I've been wondering why would
I use Shadow blur for why why would I
use Shadows of just simple shapes and
paths until I realize recently that it's
not just about Shadows you see this
image is just triangles and Shadow blow
you can make things glow and cast
shadows and it looks beautiful and it's
it's PR cheap so you you can use very
very small things to add a lot to the
visuals when comes time to compress your
animation um the best technique so far
is PNG bootstrapping um
the ID is pretty simple you take your
code you load that as a gray scale into
a gray scale image and at the end of
this image you add a bit of HTML and
JavaScript I would load the image draw
it onto a canvas read the pixels and
then execute the code
back um it compress really good and on
top of that uh because this is jzip in
the end uh or deflate you can use
additional tools like gz thermal to
inspect the the deflate stream and
optimize your code compressive even
better so it's really really
good um the basic setup for that is so
first line you have your PNG image so
all the binary stuff then a canvas
element an image that loads hash which
is image and unload you you draw the
pixels three back add them to a string
and evaluate on the last
line so this is how you make tiny audio
visual
demos and I think it's about coding time
yeah shall we do
this
okay so for today um I was thinking of
revisiting an effect or something that I
have not done in a
while um I was thinking of doing some
kind of U plants growing or something
that Forks into like small threads and
swirls around with colors and maybe
looking a bit like fireworks or
something like this and with sound so if
you try to think a bit about it and uh
now we should try to make something like
this shall
we yeah sounds
good
okay oh that's my
slide and uh Yep this is the
file uh let's say hello
let's okay we've got aell lot everything
works so we need bit of
[Music]
style uh we need a
canvas uh no element obviously if we
want to get sound this is going to be
useful and some
script
so let's style a bit our canvas so first
we need to make it full size that would
be really nice so top zero left zero
full
width full
height and oops just a
background um it would be nice to get
some kind of vignetting effect it always
looks nice especially in the on a big
screen so we just use Circle so that it
fits uh the gradient into the the whole
viewport uh let's start
from yeah some kind of bluish gray in
the
center and shade of red on the outside
okay so we got
this okay just bump it up a
little okay
so in order to draw into our canvas we
will need a to the
context uh sorry is the text big enough
yeah okay
yeah
[Music]
sorry flush flux are do you have flux oh
yes I do yes oh
sorry
clever yeah better yeah yeah nice catch
okay uh so yeah back to to the context
um okay so and um on load we
will have an update
function
and we will under our
visuals um so I would like a canvas uh
when I do animations I really I really
want to control the size of the view
portal in which I'm drawing that's why I
know exactly that if I draw a line or a
triangle that is 10 pixels I know it
will take exactly this percentage of the
viewport uh because if I use the the
current viewport size then I have no
idea how it's going to be rended I don't
know if it's going to be r on time phone
or a giant screen on the 4K so so I I
always want to to define the size of my
viewport so just the height of
512 uh
d
um yeah so this zero pipe basically cast
the next things to or the next
expression to an integer uh and I want
basically to get the width to respect
the aspect ratio so that will
[Applause]
be yeah and uh now we can
do we just go to the
middle
set
a yeah set a nice color very nice white
color for just to display some debug
output
[Music]
um and 0 0 from the
center okay that's good everything
works uh so now would be nice to
initialize our f
so we can do if
uh and yeah as you can
see this is not your typical production
project and we don't really care about
globals and yeah leaking and everything
it's it's fine this thing is just going
to live
for yeah 1 minute 2 minutes max uh so we
so if time was not defined uh we just
yes make sure the time is to zero our
frame is to zero and uh we can do time
of the next
frame two Z and uh we can
do plus plus and time plus = 1 / 60
which is like uh 60 frames per second as
our Target uh frame
rate uh let's see if that works if we
get
um mhm so that works it would work even
better if we request animation frames so
that our update function is
called for every frame that is r on
screen so we get this small counter that
is updated with frame count everything
good so far um so this is okay but what
we should do actually uh this is not
correct we what we should do is use the
current time so can use performance. now
which gives a time from the when the
application was started in millisecond
so we divide by 1,000 to get this time
in seconds and we can do while the time
is lower than the current
time and also while our time is lower
than the time of the next
frame then we'll just um time plus equal
1/
yeah let's do something like this like
just increment in small values to just
make sure that we reach uh the value we
want so when our time reaches the time
of the next frame then we incre increase
the frame count and increase the time of
the next frame to in 160th of a
second uh so things should really match
the the refresh rate of the of the
application okay everything is still
fine um so I said said that I wanted to
display some kind of things that look
like plants or branches that are
twisting around and little bit maybe
like like fireworks sping so we need to
do that
so so we
need an array of these little branches
uh that have an x and y coordinate of
course an angle that will say where it's
heading uh and then going increment that
will say how in which direction
Direction it will
twist some some kind of width I will say
how thick is the branch so that then we
can know if it's thick branch will not
twist much and it will move a bit grow a
bit faster than smaller branches so
let's start with eight we not we need um
an array of points or positions and some
kind of lifetime I will use yeah
um so here let's say Max
96 Okay so
yeah which
line oh yes thank you very
much thank you um so now we are in the
time update and we can also Now update
our
visuals uh so to do that we will
do for each for each Vine um we will run
a small update function but
will we will get the Delta x with Delta
X is um how much we are moving forward
in X or how much we are moving in x
coordinate uh so since we're dealing
with angles as is for the x coordinate
this is the cinus of the angle um we
want it to move at some oops at some
speed that is relative to the to the
thickness of a branch but not too
much um so and now we do a same for one
y coordinate so this is with Senus uh so
DX and Dy gives us how far we are moving
for the next frame for the current
Branch so we add this to the x
coordinate similarly to the y coordinate
and we also need
to to increment the angle so we do
that and we need to push the current
Point
U so we push the X which is where x
value of of Vine the Y and it's really
nice to have also the the Delta X and
Delta y that can be can be useful and
allow us to do nice things so we have
the update of visuals now we need to
render them so same
thing we look through
the come
on we look through the
vines do a small
thing
so if we're on the first one which has a
WID of high uh
eight we
will we will offset the current position
to the current position or the most
recent position of the of the branch so
that things are always centered on the
on the tip of the main branch so that
will be doing
this and now we can yeah we don't need
this anymore uh so we can begin create a
path um it's nice to know the the number
of points we're
drawing so we'll look through the
points again you see global variables
everywhere but it's it's
fine um and we decrement so we we will
look through the points from the most
recent to the to the oldest and we
move the line cursor of the canvas to
the position of of the point we are
looking at right
now and at the end we
[Applause]
stroke so we get a nice line
amazing yeah but um we are adding points
all the time so we need to to limit a
bit the number of points to do that we
can splice the array uh and basically
remove
um remove say 60 frames worth of points
to have one second worth of points and
screen so let's see yes so it it shows
the most recent one second worth of the
branch
um
on yes this is very nice so now it would
be yeah if we want the things to move
around and to grow we have to do that um
so if we want to make them twist around
we can do that every 30 frames for
instance uh so every 30 frames uh we can
basically set a random angle increments
uh between 0 well yeah between 0.5 and5
so every 30 frames it should just twist
around yeah uh you sorry you saw that it
goes a bit crazy it's really TW too fast
so it's because I forgot to uh factor of
the angle increment by the size of a or
by the thickness of a branch so now this
branch which is supposedly very thick
with very
little yeah
um let's try to do
this yeah that would be a bit nicer um
so we also need to to branch of to to
Fork this BR so uh we need to do that as
long as the thickness is yeah greater
than one we don't want like infinitely
small
branches and we just Branch randomly um
so if the random number is greater than
say the lifetime of a branch divided
by some big
number yeah let's see let's see how it
work um we will need to push a new
Vine and let's see how we Define the
first
[Music]
one so the position of the of a branch
of a new Branch will be the position of
a current
Branch so same X Y same angle same
angular speed um the light of the
thickness will be half thickness let's
say uh an empty list of points because
we're starting
fresh um we don't want the current
Branch or the new Branch to live longer
than its parent so we will use the
minimum of the current lifetime of a
branch and some random value that is BAS
thickness of a current Branch too so
that would be so v.l which is the
current lifetime or the current lifetime
of a branch and an integer value
that is related to the width of the
current Branch times some factor it's
not really important and some random
value to make it vary a bit so that uh
so that the lifetime of this new Branch
will depend on the thickness of current
branch and just wiggle a little bit but
it will not out leave a current
Branch so let's see that
works yeah Okay so we've got this thing
yeah
uh yeah we want things to leave a little
bit to leave a bit longer than one
second so let's put it to five and we
see all these
things uh these things that we just saw
uh spinning around it's because we
forgot to basically decrease the the
lifetime of the branches so we'll we'll
do that uh so to do
the the decrease of the lifetime of the
branches we just do a
filter and we just
do so this will basically decrease the
lifetime and filter it if the lifetime
becomes faly becomes zero it just pops
out from the list so that should be a
bit
nicer
yes this
is yeah okay looks a bit nicer um yeah
also
um okay something that might be
difficult to see now uh unless we are
lucky is
that the branches will basically die off
completely when the lifetime is is
over so then you will see this nice
thread and just pops out just disappears
so we should basically splice the list
of points based on
the how long the current branch has to
live uh we can do it like
this and it should look a bit nicer
already okay we don't see it so
much
um let's do this a bit Yeah divide it
once more by two the probability of
branching off should make it a bit less
crowded yeah it looks a bit
nicer um okay so it would be nice to add
some color
and so where we
draw we can do it there
um yeah we we don't have so many
branches so on screen so it's it's okay
to use H in that case um it would be
nice to have um the view of a branch
depend on the where it's
heading um
so uh since the the U in hsl is in
degree and we deal with radiant radiant
are basically from 0 to 6 each uh
multiplying by 60 is just maps to 360
Degrees um something hyper saturated and
it would be nice also to make the
thickness depend or thickness the
Luminosity depend on the thickness so
what uh the thicker branch of the the
older branch is the brighter it
is
so and that is in percentages uh
Luminosity yep so you see some some nice
colors
already yeah um yeah I
mention Shadow blur that makes things
look really nice or really cheap so
let's do a bit of
that uh so we can set the shadow BL Z
and we need to set the shadow
color shadow
color so now things should glow a bit
here yeah that looks already a bit nicer
uh uh yep okay
so
yeah now maybe we should try to add some
sound that would be
nice
so okay
water thank
[Applause]
you uh when I was talking earlier you
saw these barbaric pieces of code so I
will not type that live uh at is not the
header of a wave file so I I have a
backup
plan
so this
is this looks like a lot of cheating uh
but this uh this array of note
frequencies is basically so that uh you
don't suffer through me trying to
compose something that sounds melodic
it's yeah just to spare your ears
basically
and
also at the
end and you see this uh tiny this line
here uh but basically checks if the
source of the sound of the audio element
is set it basically tells us do I need
to generate the sound or is it generated
already so at the end in our where we
are about to render visuals we can
basically
yeah check this Boolean and if we need
to run s we run s otherwise we just run
visuals as we did
before
um
okay
um yes okay so we will need to round
there the sound so I
just yeah
yeah that's okay don't even need
that uh so when we
are in the time
update uh then when we are looking
through our time um we need to check
okay are we about to do we need to
create the sound buffer or do we are we
done with the sound buffer so in this
case if we need to create the sound we
do just that
otherwise yeah it's okay so we
need we need a value that tells us how
far we are in the current note that we
are going to play uh so we can do just
time modular one so it will be like one
note will last one second let's do
something like this um we take
our it was yeah not indexed and we can
increment it
uh when Frack is zero um because the
value here the increment here is a is a
fractional power two it will it will
align nicely and powers of two and
everything um and so when I do Modular
One and it's exactly an integral value
it will be zero so I can do if the
fractional value of the time is zero
then it will increment our note
index um
we can do
also B+
127 uh this will add the current value
to our sound buffer which is a string
for now
and when we R the sound um here we
create the header of a 16 khz web file
which get the uh we Bas 64 version of
the sound buffer P it to it and play the
sound uh so St Str is the sound buffer
more or less it's a string of sound
buffer so we here we append new values
to the sound buffer and the value will
be let's say uh time
times uh frequency a current
note
uh the array of notes was 48 Valu so
doing the end uh we'll basically look
through in case we get request too many
notes um so doing this will give us an a
variable that will increment uh and
follow the frequency of the note we
desire uh we can do Modular One uh which
will give us a s trof uh it would just
get um value that will increment from 0
to one and then back to zero and one
like So to fillat that we saw yesterday
in Paul's talk so we do
that and we need to add some kind of
envelope to it so that um we can shape
the sound through time or through the
duration of the note and we will start
at full intensity and just make the
intensity of the note decrease linearly
with a with the duration of the note so
so our so tro will just Decay linearly
no problem and we need to apply a bit of
volume so let's say 16 for
now hopefully everything
works nothing
works this
is
okay
okay let's
see suppos audio sorry supposed to be
audio yes ah uh we should be
audio
is it one yeah um yeah it's
black
[Applause]
h ah yes we did not do
that
this is a backup plan in case something
like this
happens
okay okay so let's uh let's give a
backup plan for now we're not there yet
we still have seven minutes um
okay
what what am I doing wrong here
um
okay
that's
okay okay I think was sound yes of
course the sorry um what happens here is
that um I did not update the way that I
check what is the current time um by
current time I mean how far do I need to
render things uh so now that I want to
generate the sound when I want to
generate the sound I want to
generate frames for the max value and
otherwise I want to generate until the
current time of the sound the current
position of the sound uh do I set yeah
okay Ma let's say 48 yeah
[Music]
okay
something I forgot to do um here in the
Declaration of the branches is that I
have this Max that represent the
duration of the animation in seconds one
second is 60 frames and I forgot to
multiply lifetime of a branch by
so
nice Okay
we
good okay um the notes are a bit slow so
maybe we can
[Music]
up um and
um we can make it also more interesting
because at the beginning you you saw it
sounded like low like low paste uh thing
and I kind of like it so maybe we can do
something
like if the
time
sorry uh for every every second that is
that has eight in the binary
presentation Set uh we can go fast and
otherwise we just go slow um let's say
even very
slow so at the beginning we should have
very
yeah it goes very
slow and then it should just
go so we have one instrument which is
like a s too um we can probably make
things a little bit
nicer uh by adding another
instrument some kind of u a cord or some
would be nice and the slow moving cord
in the background uh without a be bit of
depth to sound uh we can do that by
using um a sinusoidal
oscillator so we can do again we need to
factor by the time and we can do not
frequency and if we want this thing to
just uh go very slowly we can use the
time value and just shift it by two so
that uh we get like every four seconds
uh when you do bino shift uh by two to
the right it just divide by four and get
inal value uh so just change or move to
the next note every 4 seconds and uh we
are inside the MAF doc so we need to go
from 0 to Pi / two to go full
circle so we do that um for this code I
I don't really need an envelope I just
want this score to be always there uh so
envelope but it still needs a volume um
or we can do
that
[Music]
yes a small
difference
um maybe I
can and
um it would be nice also that this
melody thing is not always at the same
volume would be nicer to have a little
bit of variation uh so we can do
that uh yeah I'm just increasing the
volume it sounds a bit slow for me don't
know about you guys uh so we just start
from a base volume of 24 for the the
melody and we would just wiggle around
using a cus based on the time I's say
times the time
maybe yeah that goes too fast oh maybe
not
not let's wait for the
[Music]
[Laughter]
melody
um here you see also that uh we are
rending all the points of our our
branches um it looks nice but we can
probably do something a little bit nicer
so here in the rendering Loop let's say
that we pick uh one point or every eth
Point um we want something that tells
us basically here we normalize our
position inside the list of points so
that we know if we're at the very
beginning zero or at the very end one
and multiply by by eight so that we just
extend this small bit of line
um and we can and then start from the
position of the
point
and use this e value that gives us how
far we are inside the line to basically
draw a tiny line that goes in the
direction of the branch at this point in
time let's see how it looks so you see
this bit of line that grows as a trail
and also it should look very nice when
the when the branch is DED off because
when we should just go
back and you saw this uh yeah you saw
this onad hand what about we add an
image
[Applause]
here and then we just do this okay okay
everything's still
fine
um
[Music]
so yeah when we are back to the row um
if we on the first Branch it would be
nice to have a little sprite like some
little guy walking along the the branch
so let's let's do that uh we need to
rotate to adjust to the direction of the
the tip of the branch so we rotate using
the angle of the branch then we will
need to restore
that and we will draw
image a current image uh we can use the
frame the current frame index multiply
by four so that it goes a little bit
faster and uh yeah my Sprite sheet here
is 128 uh Sprite are 16 pixels y so
using and 112 basically gives me the
exposition of the current frame that I
want to display and the Sprite is so 16
by 24 let's under it at 0 and like this
so we got this little yeah person
working along the line except it's not
placed
corly um so now we can move it back on
the line and offset it a little bit by a
few
pixels yeah and now it's working on top
of the
branch and yeah it's just a little thing
that has some
visuals
yeah
okay and uh yeah I think this is this is
not too bad for about yeah 30 minutes of
code yeah okay maybe it looks a little
bit complex but you you saw it's very
small building blocks it doesn't take
too much to to create things and I'm
sure you all have crazy ideas floating
in your head so don't don't be shy and
just go ahead and you you can make these
things it's just just use small things
and AD so in the end I would just like
to say thank you very much to J for
having me and
you can find me on Twitter P1 I would
like to say a big thank you also to
feris from art TRS feris tweets now who
help me with a musical direction for
today so that I don't destroy your ears
this morning thank you thank you Matthew
thank
[Music]
you
for